Hess: Hello and welcome.
Thanks for coming to the last
session of the last day
and hearing a little bit
about web services
on Google App Engine.
So my name is Ron Hess,
and I'm a developer evangelist
with Salesforce.com.
And I have with me
Ryan Marples,
also a developer evangelist.
Ryan, raise your hand.
Stand up.
And Iein Valdez
from Appirio.
Appirio is a partner
of Salesforce.
[applause]
And has a cheering section.
Appirio is a partner of Google
and a partner of Salesforce.
And he's built
a really interesting demo.
So we're going to do
a couple of things today.
We're going to talk
about some code.
We're gonna talk about
some new technology,
an open source project,
and we're gonna
see some demos.
So before we get
too far into it,
I'd like to ask the audience:
How many people
are familiar with Salesforce?
have heard of the platform?
Maybe used it.
Maybe they use it
at a current company.
Fantastic.
Okay, that's a great showing.
So a lot of the stuff
that I'm gonna talk about,
Salesforce you'll
understand right away.
And then of course
you're at a Google conference,
so you will understand
how exciting App Engine is.
This is our
safe harbor statement.
It's a reminder to make
your purchasing decisions
based on current features.
You can read more about this
on salesforce/investor.
Today the agenda,
as I mentioned,
we're gonna talk about
Force.com platforms
to get you up to speed on all
the exciting features there.
And we're gonna talk
about how we're connecting
these two clouds--
the Force.com platform
is our cloud--
and the Google App Engine--
and all of the apps
that run on Google
represent the Google cloud,
and how these two platforms
actually work together.
We're going to talk
about how we build that bridge
so that they can communicate.
We'll also show
a simple Hello World,
because I love
to show some code
in all of my sessions.
And then Ryan's built
an exciting
product catalog demo,
so he's gonna
demonstrate that.
And then Iein has
a demo from Appirio
that shows
real-world-type solution
that combines
both of these clouds.
And of course we'll
have time for Q & A.
So first, to understand
the Salesforce cloud,
the Force.com platform,
I want to break down
what we offer
into these three categories.
It's the real-time
infrastructure,
which is the bottom row--
I want to make sure
you can all see that--
and all the features
it brings to our cloud.
Then we'll talk a little
about the cloud platform.
And finally the cloud apps.
That's the Salesforce cloud,
the service cloud,
and your application
that you build on our platform.
Those are all on top,
and they enjoy all
the services below.
So on the infrastructure side,
we are a SAS 70 certified.
We are ISO 27001 certified.
So when you build apps
on our platform,
you're enjoying
the certified platform.
We have proven scalability,
real-time upgrades,
a trust system--
all of these kind
of infrastructure features
that you also enjoy
on Google App Engine.
Then on top of that,
we have the cloud platform.
And our cloud platform
has a bunch of modules
that are built in
that you don't have
to code for.
A great example of one
of these built-in modules
is our real-time workflow
and approvals.
So with our platform,
each user can be a recipient
or a participant
in a workflow process,
and they can be an approver
or just an observer
of a workflow.
And so workflow
is one of the things
that we provide for you.
You don't have to build that.
You don't have to code that.
Along with workflow,
there's analytics,
there's a content library,
there's unlimited
customizations.
And as you build customizations
on our platform,
we build the UI for you.
So all those things combined
make it a very fast way
to build apps in the could.
I'll talk a little bit more
about that in a minute,
but the really exciting thing
is how we're gonna combine
these clouds.
So let me keep moving.
So with the Force.com platform,
you do get all the benefits
of building apps in the cloud.
You get no-hassle upgrades.
You build it
on our infrastructure.
We take care
of all the gunk,
and you can build your app
and focus on the value add
that your company brings.
And this is the same
with Google's clouds.
So again, you're seeing
a parallel here.
Things that we offer
and things that they offer
are very similar.
We're going to show you
how you don't have to choose.
You can actually combine.
So this represents--
This shows you
all of the things
that you might have
to build otherwise,
but on our platform,
we provide these for you.
So it's a great way
to get started,
build something quickly.
App exchange is our directory
of applications.
Our real-time content library
and so on.
All of these things
are build for you,
and you'll be able to access
them on Force.com platform.
So many apps have been built
using these features,
but those apps may or may not
be able to talk
to the Google apps.
So how do we kinda combine
both of these clouds?
So in order
to understand that,
how we're going to
combine everything,
I want to talk about
Google's cloud architecture.
And this is
a cloud that I got--
a slide that I got
from my host, Scott McMullan.
And Scott,
are you here?
Scott's not here right now,
but Scott gave me this could
to understand how Google
sees their architecture.
And you can see
what they've got
is Google Apps
like Mail, Calendar,
Documents, and Gadgets.
They also have
third-party apps.
And those sit on top
of Google's infrastructure.
And inside of Google's
infrastructure,
they represent
Google App Engine.
So that's where
App Engine sits.
And you can see that
App Engine is already built
to handle integrations with
other third-party services.
We'll talk about
specifically how that's done
for the next few slides.
But I wanted to show
this architecture
and alongside
the Salesforce architecture
so you can see
how really similar they are.
So there's a slide.
You saw that earlier.
It's the infrastructure.
On top of the infrastructure
is the platform.
On top of the platform
are the apps.
And there have been more
than 850 ISV apps
built on our platform.
We have a million users
and 60,000--
Over a million users
and over 60,000 customers.
So all of these people
are building and using
our cloud today,
but they may actually
need to talk to an application
that's built
for the Google platform.
So how do we connect these?
And what do you really gain
by connecting these clouds?
So this is important
to understand.
Why would you want
to combine these?
What are you really
gonna get out of it?
Well, what we feel
is that these two clouds
are non-rival.
We see many customers of ours
that use our sales automation
but they need Google apps.
And so Google
is able to go in
and sell Google apps
to those customers.
And many of Google's customers
that actually use Gmail
and Docs and Spreadsheets
and Calendar
actually need a sales
automation application as well.
And so we can sell
into those customers as well.
So now we've got customers,
and Appirio knows this
because they build
for both platforms.
The ability to leverage
these two clouds,
working together.
So if you're a developer,
and the application
that you're building
on our platform
needs to talk to Google,
it can.
And if you're
building an app
on Google App Engine,
and you need to talk
to a sales system
like we have
on our Force.com platform,
you can do that too.
So you no longer
have to choose.
You can use one or the other
or both in a combination
and build this integration
and deliver enhanced value
to your customers.
So today what we're
specifically gonna talk about
is building Java applications
on App Engine
that talk to,
that read and write
onto the Force.com
cloud platform.
So I've got
another slide here
that kind of shows you
what we're going
to be talking about today.
The rest of the day
we're going to talk about
these three clouds
in the middle.
You can see Google App Engine
on the left there.
You can see
the Web Service Client,
the Partner Library,
and the SOAP API,
and those in combination
allow you to communicate
across these two clouds.
So let's take a closer look
at the pieces
that we're going
to discuss.
There are three things
that we're going to talk about.
Gonna go into some detail
on each of these.
The first one
is the Web Service Client.
So the Web Service Client
is just that.
It's a client that runs
on App Engine,
and it provides two features
that we need
to communicate with
the Force.com database.
It provides parsing
and transport.
Go into those in a little bit
more detail later.
The Web Service Client actually
uses the Partner Library.
The Partner Library
is, again, Java code,
but it's generated.
So you don't have
to generate it.
And in our open source project,
we generated one for you.
So you can get started
without generating any of that.
And then
on the Force.com side
is the SOAP API.
That's how
all of the integrations
that you build
for Force.com
communicate
with our database
using the SOAP API.
So that's provided
by Salesforce.
So you don't need
to build that either.
to build any of these,
but I wanted
to show each of them
in some more detail
so you can understand
just how they're all
gonna work together.
So first is the Force.com
SOAP API.
And this is a standard
spaced API.
It's SOAP and WSDL.
It's exposed as a WSDL
on our website.
So as a developer,
when you sign up
for the developer edition,
you'll be able
to download the WSDL,
and that describes
all the methods and objects
that you can interact with
on our database.
And you get
basic CRUD operations,
like read, create,
update, delete, and so on.
There's also
special operations--
for example, send e-mail,
convert lead,
and even metadata operations
that you can use to create
new tables, new fields,
and so on.
These are all exposed as WSDL.
Today, we're going to be
talking about the partner WSDL,
which is just
one of the WSDLs.
There's also
an Enterprise WSDL.
But the SOAP API
is standard space.
So I don't want to go into
too much detail on this.
You can read more about this
on developer.force.com.
It's called Web Services API.
So it's the first thing
that we need to understand,
and it's already built for us,
so we're not gonna spend
a lot of time on that.
On the other side
of the bridge
that we're building here
is the Web Service Client.
Now this is very exciting
because this is brand-new.
This has just been
open sourced this week.
I don't know if you saw
the press release yesterday.
This is an open source project.
It's built on a high performance
streaming interface for Java.
We had to make
some minor change
for App Engine,
but I'm going to show you
just exactly
what we had to do there
to get it up and running.
And it wasn't much,
I'll tell you.
It was very exciting
to see how quickly
it all came together.
This is available
on code.google.com.
The project name
is sfdc-wsc.
And you can link to that
from our
developer.force.com homepage.
We'll have those URLs
at the end of the talk.
So what does this
Web Service Client give us?
Well, there's two things
that we absolutely need.
We need parsing
and transport.
Parsing because
we want to use a WSDL
that maybe generated
a rev over time.
So we need to be able
to parse this WSDL.
And that actually--
The exciting thing
about this library
and Google App Engine
is that this is not specific
to Force.com.
This could be used
with any WSDL.
So if there's one thing
that you take away
from this talk today,
it's that now
with Google App Engine
you can use Web Services.
This client will work
with other WSDLs.
Now we've only tested it
with the Force.com WSDL.
But you could use it
with any document literal WSDL.
And we've provided support for
several object types in there.
So you can look in there
and see if the object types
that you need
are supported or not.
And you can see
the source code
and see how to support
additional object types
that might be more specific
for your WSDL.
But again, it's not specific
to Force.com.
Additionally,
the Web Service Client
provides the transport methods,
and this is based on--
Because this runs
on App Engine,
it's based on the native
features of App Engine,
the UrlFetch.
And I'm sure you've seen
or heard about UrlFetch
during the talks earlier.
And I'll show you
just a couple of lines of code
about discussing that.
So let's take a look
at the transport layer.
Now I wanted
to show this code
because this is
actually the code
that I had to write
to implement
our Web Service Client
on App Engine.
So of the thousands
of lines of code
included in
the Web Service Client,
these are the only things
that I had to actually modify.
Our client uses
a streaming interface.
The streaming interface
is not available on App Engine.
Instead you use
a fetch mechanism.
So I had to write a fetch
that actually
exposes the data
as a stream.
So you can see I'm calling
setPayload
to take all
of the chunk of data
that you're asking
to be queried.
Say the query string that you
want to read from Force.com
or the query--
or the records
that you want to write
to Force.com,
and then you call fetch.
And I'm just checking
the response code
and then getting
the content.
All of these
are provided for me
by the App Engine library.
So I didn't have
to write any of that.
I just had to write
this one port.
So if you haven't
ported your Java code
to App Engine yet,
the message here
is it's really easy.
You should give it a try.
Most of the Java
that I ran across
just dropped right in
and worked first time.
So this is the heart
of the transport.
And again,
this is open source.
I'm not gonna go into too much
more detail on the source code.
You can find
the source code online.
Happy to talk to you
about that process later,
porting that application
to App Engine.
But the exciting thing
was it worked pretty quickly,
and it worked right away.
The other thing that we need
is parsing.
So the Web Service Client
has a parsing tool
built into it.
And with this tool,
you generate
the Java objects.
So you provide a WSDL,
and you run
this command line,
and it generates a JAR
that has all the methods
and all the objects
that were in the WSDL.
And that code works
on App Engine.
So when I run this command,
I generate
this output JAR file.
What does it build me?
Well, it builds me
the next piece of the chain,
the Partner Library.
And we call this
It could also be
the Enterprise Library.
If you're familiar
with our WSDLs,
we have
a strongly-typed WSDL
and a loosely-typed WSDL
so that you can
write applications
that work with multiple
Salesforce orgs.
Or if you're writing
for your own org,
you can use
the Enterprise WSDL as well.
But basically, you generate
that JAR file,
and it has
the objects and methods.
And the transport classes
come in the WSC JAR,
which is also
out on the project.
And you drop those into
your App Engine project.
And as soon as you do that,
you're done.
I mean, you are ready
to build your Hello World
because that's
all you need to do.
Inside your application
it exposes
as a connection object.
So I think the next thing
we want to do--
So we've looked at
the Web Service Client.
We've looked at the SOAP API.
Any questions about
the Partner Library
or any of these pieces?
I'm happy to take questions
while we're going,
'cause sometimes that's
when the questions come up.
Or we can save
the questions for the end.
So we've looked
at all the pieces.
Now let's just look
at a basic Hello World program.
This is Java program
that does three things.
It's going to create
a connection config.
It's going to log in,
which is calling
new connection.
Then it's going
to create an object,
which we call an SObject.
It's going to populate
fields on that object.
And then it's gonna
call create.
So this is interesting,
but I'd rather
show you this one.
I'd rather go in
and demo this one.
So let's go ahead
and switch into this now.
And hope everything works
just like I like.
Okay, so here
is the source code
for my Hello World.
I know it's very simple,
but I wanted to show you
something simple first.
So let's take
a look at this.
And it's pretty--
pretty basic.
But let's do this
the fun way.
Let's delete everything
and build it from scratch.
So I'm gonna go ahead
and show you
how I build these things
from scratch.
I'm gonna use snippets.
And the first snippet
I'm gonna bring in
is the Hello World servlet.
So it's very basic.
I haven't done
anything here yet.
I've just got
a get and a post method
in my servlet.
And I've added these includes,
these imports.
So I'm ready to go.
Nothing surprising yet.
Now I need to--
When I call get
on my Hello World--
Well, first let me tell you
what the Hello World
is going to do.
Hello World's
gonna run on App Engine,
and it's gonna
create an account
on Salesforce.
We'll call the account
Hello World.
So that's what
it's gonna do.
To do that,
I'm gonna bring in a form.
The form is just
going to allow me
to type in a name,
the name of my account.
I'm gonna type in
"hello world."
This is, again, basic.
Nothing special here.
Got a form.
Now I need
to declare the connection.
Now we're gonna start
to use the Partner Library.
So I've just brought in
the logging method,
and a user name,
and a password,
and a partner connection.
This is the partner connection
that I'm gonna interact with,
and that's what
we're going to use
to actually communicate.
So there we go.
We're almost ready.
We need two more things.
We need to log in.
So I'll bring that
down here into the post.
In which case, we're gonna
create a connector config,
which holds
our user name and password,
and then we're going
to log in.
That's called new connection.
All right,
so nothing special there yet.
We're just gonna log in.
And finally, we're ready
to create an account.
So what you can see here,
as on the slide,
I just create a new object,
populate a few fields,
set the type of object
that I want to create.
This can be a custom object
or a standard object.
And then I'm gonna call
connection create.
So there we go.
That's the entire
Hello World application.
I'll save that.
And now I'm going
to launch that.
Okay, it's running.
And it's telling me
that I need a new SDK.
Actually,
it's warning me
that the SDK
has been updated.
So I'll take that on note,
and I will update that
a little bit later.
But right now I want
to go to local host,
and we'll run this.
Let's see.
Got one that's ready to go.
Run, okay.
There's the servlet.
There's the hello servlet
that I want to run.
There it is,
"Hello, world."
Okay, so this
is an input form.
Now we're just about ready.
I'm gonna type
"Hello World Google IO."
Okay.
Here we go,
I'm gonna create that account.
Now, I didn't put
a lot of user interaction.
I didn't put a wait.
It's just going to reload
that page when I'm done.
So now I need to switch
into a browser
and log in to Salesforce.
So do I have a browser
that's up and running?
Um, I don't.
What am I gonna do?
I'm gonna launch
a fresh browser
just to avoid confusing
my colleagues here.
They have everything set up.
There's the Salesforce page.
I've got a little
log in link.
This is the log in--
This is the application that
I inserted the data into.
I'll go to the accounts tab.
And we should see
"Hello World Google IO."
And there it is.
If we go and visit
this account,
we'll see a time stamp
from today.
There it is.
6:09 P.M.
That must be--
Must be in London,
the time zone setting.
Okay.
So that is the simple
Hello World.
I know it's awfully simple,
but I wanted to show you
just how quick and easy it is
to actually build something
that's starting to communicate
with these two clouds.
Now, that was interesting,
but what's really interesting
are some of the things
that you can do
if you get a little more time
and you get a little more
Java experience.
So what I asked Ryan to do
was to take the next step,
say build something
really interesting,
not just a Hello World.
So I got to do
the easy one.
So now I think
I'd like to ask Ryan
to come up and show us
the next step
in this evolution.
Thanks, Ryan.
Do you--Is your mic on?
Marples: Uh, I believe so.
I believe it is.
Um, okay, so Ron showed
kind of a functional demo.
What I wanted to show
was something
a little more real world.
So let me set the scenario
before I start
showing stuff here.
The idea is
I'm gonna represent
a company called
Stratus Interiors,
and I'm an interior furniture
vendor.
Stratus is a type of cloud,
but I don't think
anybody got that.
So anyway
we'll skip over that.
The idea is--Now I'm
a Salesforce customer,
and I've got a lot
of data in Salesforce.
I manage my products,
I manage my sales reps,
I manage my leads.
And I wanted to use
Google App Engine,
and specifically
I have a developer
who has Java experience
who'd like to build
an application on Java
to actually produce
an online product catalog
and collect some leads
in from users.
So that was the challenge,
and that's--
This new tool kit
that Ron's just talked about
helps us do that.
So let's talk
about how that's gonna work.
I will create
a new window here,
and this is actually live
right now.
stratusinteriors.appspot.com.
So this is a Google Java
App Engine application.
And when I come
to the catalog page,
it looks like a very simple
product catalog.
But actually
what's happening is--
we'll look at the code
in a minute--
but these products,
these chairs,
these various
pieces of furniture,
this is actually
a data-driven page
that's coming
directly from Salesforce.
We're actually
feeding the data in live.
The other piece
of functionality we have,
in addition to displaying
the product catalog,
is I can come in and say,
"Well, maybe
I'm interested in this,"
and I can actually put in
some information here.
So I will call myself
Google IO.
And I'll make up
an e-mail address.
And I'll say maybe I'm
interested in the pricing
and maybe the customer reviews
of this particular product.
And I'll hit request there.
And that's actually
doing the opposite.
Instead of reading data
from Salesforce,
we're actually pushing
data into Salesforce
and creating an inquiry
within Salesforce.
So again,
we're really displaying
how we can keep the data
and kinda the business process
within Salesforce
but the applications live.
So if I were to want to go
and update a product,
add a new product,
I would just go into Salesforce,
add that product,
don't have to touch the website.
And similarly,
as leads come into the website,
I don't need to have anybody
e-mailing things around
or exporting CSVs.
It's a dynamic link
into Salesforce.
Just to prove this,
let's actually go
log in to Salesforce.
So here we are.
And this is the Stratus eStore
application that I have.
And you can see these
are the catalog entries
we just looked at
a minute ago.
So if I go look
at one of these items,
we have the--in this case
it's a chair.
We have the image URL.
We have the description.
I could actually
change that
and have that come up
back on the site.
We have inquiries.
Got a bunch in here.
Apparently Bart Simpson's
interested in a lounger.
And here you go.
Here's the one we just created.
So similar to Ron's example.
The other thing I'll do, just
'cause we showed two inputs.
We haven't really
shown an output.
Just to kinda prove
this is live,
I'll come back in here,
and we'll change one of these.
We'll take chair one, which
should be the first product,
and we'll edit this.
And instead of saying
it's really cool,
we'll say it's awesome.
And we'll go ahead
and save that.
And we'll come back here,
and we'll come
to our catalog.
And there we are.
It says it's awesome.
So again,
that's the power of this,
is, you know, holding
the corporate data
within Salesforce
but driving an application.
So close these two
back here.
Just a couple of things
I wanted to point out
about how this was built.
The first thing,
making the connection.
What I did here
is I realized, you know,
in some situations
users will be supplying
their Salesforce credentials
and logging on every time.
In this case,
I just have a special account.
So I actually
created an account called--
I think I called it
API basically.
And it has the right permissions
within Salesforce.
What I wanted to do was log on
as that particular user.
When I realized that,
you know, a catalog is not--
I did the update now.
I can change something,
and it's live.
But in realistic terms,
you don't need
the product catalog to be
updated right to the second.
So I've created
a little session manager,
which has handled
some caching.
So what it does is
it logs on to Salesforce,
it takes the session ID,
and throws it in Memcache
for about an hour.
So then as subsequent
requests come in,
it's reusing the same session.
It doesn't have
to recreate that.
So I just created
a little session manager class
that can help you out
with that.
And you can find that code
if you're interested
in leveraging that
up on the Google Code Project.
Also just to show, you know,
instead of hard coding
your username and password,
you can do something like
a servlet parameter,
which is in the web xml.
I've got that in there.
The other thing
is just the retrieving data.
I don't think
we've shown this.
Ron talked about
the inserts.
This is just to show you
another example
of pulling data out.
That conn variable,
that's that connection object
that represents that API
into Salesforce.
In this case,
we're calling query.
Now you may look at this
and say,
"Oh, it's a SQL statement."
Well, this is actually
the Salesforce's query language.
So if you've used
Salesforce before
from a developer perspective,
you'll find this
very familiar.
But if you haven't,
this is actually Salesforce's
query language.
It's a powerful query language.
We can do joins,
and relationships,
and filters,
and all this kinda stuff.
So I'm just doing
a simple query in this case,
asking for a few fields
from my catalog entry object
and doing a simple order.
And then I'm getting
my results back.
And I get this getRecords,
and I get this array
of the SObjects,
which are effectively
Salesforce objects.
And here I'm just
looping through.
What I did was I created
a CatalogEntry object,
which is just a little
plain old Java object
with a couple properties
that I can pass on to my JSP.
And I'm just kind of calling
from SObject,
which converts it,
and that passes on to the data.
So that's the gist of it.
I hope that's useful.
Go up to
the Google Code Project,
and you can see
the code for this
as well as download it,
and you could
even check it out live.
stratusinteriors.appspot.com.
I think at this point,
I'm gonna hand it over to Iein.
Valdez:
Thanks, Ryan and Ron.
So I'm Iein Valdez.
I work in product development
at Appirio.
And we help accelerate
the adoption
of cloud computing
within the Enterprise.
And I think it's fitting
that this session
is about connecting
the clouds.
And, you know, our business
is helping companies
like Harrah's Entertainment
take advantage of platforms
like Google Apps
and also Salesforce.com.
So I'm gonna show you
a demo we built for Harrah's,
which essentially
connects Salesforce
with Google Apps
and App Engine,
and how we used
the Web Services Client
that Ron and team
put together
to make
that connection happen.
So let me--
The premise here,
the background
is that Harrah's
uses Salesforce
to manage
their host process
and reservation process
for VIPs.
So you have
high stakes VIPs.
They have a designated host.
A host helps manage
their visits,
manage their
travel arrangements,
and makes sure they have
an overall excellent experience.
So let me show you
what that interface looks like.
And we're gonna go into, uh,
Salesforce.com.
And I'm gonna log in as--Oops.
I'm gonna log in as Nicole,
who is a host at Harrah's.
So...
Nicole...
And we're gonna log in.
And what we see here
is the demo instance
that we've set up
for Harrah's Entertainment.
And this is where
Nicole, the host,
manages her day.
So this is her home page
where she can see dashboard,
reservations coming in,
event popularity,
also manage tasks.
You can see that this
is where guests are managed.
So her VIPs are managed here
as well as the reservations
that her VIPs
have entered into the system.
The one point
I want to point out,
when you see
the interface we built,
is that not unlike
the earlier catalog demo,
that the events,
which are the prizes
in the game that I'm gonna
show you in a second,
come right out of Salesforce.
So you'll see here we have
a list of various events.
So let me actually take you
and show you what
the end result looks like.
So here--
Okay, so here is
the actual site we have,
and this is
the Total Rewards program
that Harrah's VIPs have.
I'm logged in,
in this instance, as a VIP,
and I can see that my host
is Nicole Patterson.
She's my personal concierge.
I have lots of information.
And I can--I have
my trip planner here.
And so if I want
to create a trip
and enter it into this system,
I'm able to do that.
And I can see
events coming up.
Now what we did,
at the bottom here
you'll see that we have,
you know,
Play to win Event Prizes.
And when I click this
and expand that,
this is an App Engine app
that we built
which pulls prizes
out of Salesforce.com
and allows you
to essentially play the game.
And the logic for the game
is powered in App Engine
on Java.
And as you accumulate points
and accumulate enough
to cash a prize out,
you're able
to cash the prize out.
The prize is added
to your travel reservation,
and then inside of Salesforce
Nicole's able to see that
and make sure you have
an overall great experience.
So I'm gonna go ahead
and play the game.
So let's see,
I'll roll it here,
and hopefully I can
accumulate enough points.
man: You're not winning!
Valdez: I'm not winning.
There we go, okay.
So I now have 250 points.
And you'll see there's
three prizes I could cash out.
The Price is Right Live,
Bette Midler,
or Caesars Palace Comedy.
So I'm gonna go ahead
and cash out The Price is Right.
Now before I do this,
what this does
is, at this point
when I click cash out,
it's gonna go into
Salesforce,
and it's gonna
pull up my record.
It's gonna make sure
the prize is still available,
and then it's gonna add it
to my reservation process
and then alert the host.
So I'm gonna go ahead
and click Buy.
And we see that my prize
has been redeemed.
There's my
confirmation number,
the title,
the points I redeemed,
and then sort of some detail
information about the prize.
So let's go back
into Salesforce,
and we should see
a new alert
where that prize
has been redeemed.
Wait for this to load.
Okay, so here we go.
Here's my dashboard.
And now that I see
that James Gray,
who I was logged in as,
won a slot prize, Bette Midler,
and I need to update
his guest reservation.
And so I'll go ahead
and click in here
and give you
a little bit more detail
about what that looks like.
We can see that, you know,
when this was entered in.
I'm not sure
what time zone this is.
But I get details
about the trip,
and I'm able
to kind of follow up
and manage
work flow from here.
So this essentially
is the process.
And what I want to do now
is go back to the presentation
if I can find it.
Let's see.
Hmm.
Here we go.
Where's the presentation?
I may have killed it
actually.
Yeah, I'm in Firefox.
Let's see,
can I pull it back up?
Right there.
Here we go.
Sorry.
Let me go ahead
and jump to the slide
that we were on.
Yep, start presentation,
okay.
Sorry, folks.
Technical difficulties here.
Okay, so let's talk about
why we did it this way
and what are
some of the benefits.
So we essentially built
this slot machine game
to show how Harrah's
could really create
an engaging experience
and sort of leverage
the strength of App Engine,
which would allow us
to build multiple
entertainment applications,
take advantage
of Java libraries,
and really tie those.
And, you know,
App Engine is great
for large scale
and viral distribution.
And it also allowed Harrah's
to target VIP gamers
whenever they think
about gaming
in a different context
they think about gaming.
So it was important
not that this stayed
just on a host reservation
web page,
but that we actually
allowed this game to be played
within other contexts.
And so we also
built a gadget,
which I'll show you
here in a second
which allows the game
to be played within iGoogle
or any other gadget container.
So let me go ahead
and actually do that,
and let me try
not to kill--
Here we go.
So I'm gonna go ahead
and log into iGoogle.
And I'll just show you what
that same slot machine game
looks like being run.
I'm gonna log out
and log back in as myself.
Here we go.
And what we should see here
when I got to--Oops.
Go to iGoogle
is we have our
slot machine game right here.
Now it doesn't quite
fit in this view,
but I can go ahead
and expand the gadget
and get in canvas mode.
And so here's
the game again.
And so the idea is that
if I'm a VIP,
I'm able to actually
play this game
not just on that
host reservation page,
but within iGoogle
where maybe I spend my time
looking at e-mail
and planning my trips
and so forth.
So I can, again, go ahead
and play the game here
and maybe win again.
There we go.
I can get
the Bette Midler prize,
cash it out,
and if we go back
to the host reservation page,
you'll see
that it shows up
and is recorded as another
prize that I've won.
So, I mean, that's
essentially the demo
that we wanted to show.
I had two quick pictures
I wanted to show you
about the IDE environment,
which is really talking about
building Java applications
and--all within Eclipse.
And so I'm gonna
open this up super quick.
And I have
two pictures here.
So this
is essentially a picture
of the Eclipse
IDE environment,
which you're all
familiar with and--
or most may be
familiar with.
And we've installed
the Java--the Java plugin
for App Engine.
So we're able
to build deploy apps.
And so you'll see
I've got my project here.
Now the thing
I wanted to show you
was that side by side,
you're able to essentially--
Here's my Force.com
work environment.
So I'm essentially able
to build my App Engine apps
and also work in Force.com
all within Eclipse.
And so it makes for
a really productive experience
to be able
to switch back and forth
and not have to change context.
So I just wanted to highlight
that it makes it
a easy-to-use experience.
So I'm gonna go back
to our presentation.
And I have
one other slide
to sum up here.
So coming back
to this question of--
of connecting the clouds,
we thought there were
very many advantages
to using App Engine.
Essentially we're able
to take advantage
of the Java developer community
and the libraries out there
when building these
slot machine-type applications,
and we're able to embed it
in multiple contexts,
like iGoogle.
So App Engine made it
very easy to do that for us.
And it was also
a pay-as-you-go model
for auto scaling,
'cause we didn't know
what the user utilization
of our games would be.
Now obviously there are
a ton of advantages
to using Force.com,
especially since Harrah's
uses Force
for host management,
and there are some things
we couldn't do in App Engine
that was wanted
to do in Force.
So we wanted to be able
to track these prizes,
make sure that the host
was aware of them
so that the VIP felt like
he had an excellent experience.
We were able
to trigger work flow
and manage
the guest's experience,
and also track engagement
from guests,
even for those that didn't
actually book a trip
or actually lost the game so
that there was some follow-up.
So that was essentially
what I wanted to talk about.
We're very excited about
the Web Service Client,
and back to Ron.
Hess: All right.
Make sure I've got this on.
All right,
thank you very much, Iein.
That was an exciting demo.
And thank you, Ryan,
for building
that Java catalog experience.
You can get the source code
for the catalog demo
out on--it's out on
code.google.com.
It's located in this
project repository,
which is called
sfdc-wsc.
You can link to that from
developer.force.com
where we have
an App Engine landing page.
We do have support
for Python App Engine
and Java App Engine.
And the really exciting thing
about the WSC client
for App Engine
is it really means
that you can bring
any web service
to App Engine,
not just ours.
Although we did test ours
on App Engine.
So I've got time
for questions.
So I want to see if you guys
have any questions
about what we've
talked about today
or the tool kit
or any of these technologies.
I see one question.
Go ahead and--
Yeah, go ahead and approach
the microphone,
and I'll repeat
your question as well.
man: Biggest concern
and question we have
was we were at the Force event
down at Plug and Play,
is we need
the microsecond DB
behind that
from Force to Oracle.
You know,
the 11g stuff is nice,
and it's commoditized,
but if I'm gonna pay--
and I don't mind paying--
I need the microsecond I/O
that times in and open source
[indistinct] DSS.
Is there gonna be
a premium tier for Force apps
for people who need
real-time CRM?
Like not Memcache,
'cause if I do that,
I can do it on, like,
App Engine
or any other
lap stack system.
I need, like,
10, 15, 30 second--
Mobile-ready networks
for CRM.
Hess: Okay, so let me make
sure I understand the question.
You want to--
Do you want
to combine the clouds or--
man: Yeah, we're combining
both clouds,
but we want
the premium hardware
and microsecond databases that
Oracle can give you on Force.
We don't want
just the 11g stuff.
We can get that anywhere.
If we can get that from Force,
we'll pay more,
because we have
mobile customers
who bring us 10 to 30
to 50 odd dollars a month each
all over the world, so.
Hess: You know, I don't know
the answer to that question,
so let's--
check with me afterwards,
and I'd like
to understand more.
Using an Oracle
on-premise feature?
man: No, you got Oracle
behind Force.
That's what you're on.
Hess: Yeah, but we expose
our platform
through our feature set.
man: Right, but in order
to get the time performance,
like, not an hour, we need,
like, ten minutes--
Like, doing real CRM,
trending specifically
on mobile users
go much faster than that.
So we need to be able
to get ahead of it
using CRM like yours,
see what trending's coming,
how many--
Then we can deploy
on, like, App Engine...
more instances and turn out
more of the actual use
to stay ahead of that,
'cause App Engine
kinda does
a pre-caching thing.
It tells by traffic
pre-caching, like,
little instances ready when
we're gonna get more traffic.
But Salesforce,
with a microsecond Oracle,
like times ten type
infrastructure,
versus, like, the 11g stuff,
will let us
be able to deploy faster
and see it coming faster
with CRM.
So that's what we'd like if--
And we'll pay more
if you can give us that.
Hess: Okay, I'll be happy
to talk to you
about the pricing
and availability of that--
of that type of feature,
but I want to make sure
I understand it more,
so I'd like to talk
to your afterwards
and really get
to the bottom
of the inquiry.
Any other questions
about the architecture,
combining these clouds,
or anything else?
All right, fantastic.
So if you have time,
come and see us afterwards,
ask some specific questions,
and I do thank you
for sticking around,
staying till the last session
of the last day,
and spending it with us.
Thank you very much.
[applause]